with the blitz of cards promising good
performance at 1440p and smooth VR
experiences many of us that don't have
the coin for higher reses monitor or an
HTC Vive might be left wondering where
the newer gen cards focused on good old
1080p gaming are AMD has answered that
question first by rolling out the new
Radeon rx470 under the banner of its #
better red marketing campaign and no AMD
isn't calling for the Communist Uprising
against the Nvidia bourgeois
but rather focusing more heavily on the
bang for the buck rather than every
ounce of possible performance with its
current Polaris architecture so does the
rx470 have the potential to be the
weapon of choice for the 1080p
proletariat let's find
[Music]
out G fuel is the sugar-free Alternative
Energy beverage to maintain focus and
endurance over long days and gaming
sessions save using the code Linus at
the link below so the rx470 is quite
similar to its much B Hood Big Brother
the rx480 both use a Polaris 10 series
GPU though the 470 has 32 compute units
and 2048 stream processors a bit less
than the 36 and 2304 of the 480 both use
conventional gddr5 memory with the 470
having a rather standard complement of 4
GB with a bandwidth of 211 GB per second
at only 120 watts of typical board power
the card should also be well suited for
lower-end power supplies with Headroom
to spare at 280 wats of power draw from
the wall it still has a little bit of
catching up to do in terms of matching
nvidia's current power efficiency but at
280 Watts you can get by with a very
cheap but well-built power supply just
fine this specific version of the rx470
we have on the bench today is a ni inro
plus aftermarket cooled card from
Sapphire it features a dual bios switch
in the top leftand corner of the card
which allows you to switch between quiet
mode with a low tuned fan profile or
boost mode with a Max clock speed of
1260 instead of The Quiet modes 1206 the
button right next to that switch is for
Led modes which can do basic mode
changes on the Fly to Your lighting
system on your card or you can just use
the upcoming tricks 3.0 software to do
more specific alterations to the RGB
LEDs you can even remove the dual 95mm
dual bearing fans by just removing one
screw each allowing you to clean or
replace them with ease the Sapphire
version comes with two HDMI 2.0 and two
display Point 1.4 ports while the
reference Edition adds the third DP
connector at the expense of one HDMI and
speaking of which if you're more
interested in the reference version it
looks virtually identical to the 480 but
but unlike the 480 which was build as a
VR for the masses card the 470 is being
marketed as a brilliant HD gaming for
all there actually hasn't been a card
released yet under
$200 at launch that can max out new
titles at 1080p so can the rx470 be the
first let's Dive Right into our
Benchmark results to find out starting
off with rise of the Tomb Raider at very
high presets the 470 got 64 FPS in dx11
and 67 in D X12 at 1080p we saw
similarly strong results in Hitman with
our settings maxed out with the card
even breaking the 70 FPS Mark in dx11
moving on to the classically punishing
title Crisis 3 we can find that yes the
480 can run Crisis 3 at 60 FPS with very
high settings in HD 66 frames to be
exact but there's a more interesting
question to be answered as well with
this card how well does it take
advantage of Vulcan the new open- source
API that AMD is backing fairly heavily
well there are only three games
currently out that we're aware of with
vulcan's support the most recent of
which is Doom although it's not exactly
the hardest game to run Vulcan
definitely gave us a performance
increase with the rx470 pushing 107
frames per second with Vulcan as opposed
to 86 with openg GL 4.5 Doom doesn't
support direct X in case you are
wondering notably it beat out the more
expensive GTX 1060 which managed 101 FPS
in Vulcan and speaking of expense cost
is the only area where we felt the rx470
fell a little short don't get me wrong
at $180 for the reference Edition it's a
very good bang for your buck card and
definitely not what I'd have called
expensive however at only $20 cheaper
than the more powerful rx480 the pricing
is more than a little confusing this
card really should have been a bit
cheaper to be a more enticing option
however at $70 less than nvidia's
current mid-range offering the GTX 1060
the rx470 may even undercut a possible
upcoming GTX
1050 only time will tell but at least
for now if you want to slay just about
anything at 1080p without paying a ton
of extra for compute cores that you
simply don't need there isn't much
reason to go with something else even if
you're not chomping at the bit to tag
all of your tweets with # better red
Mast drop has brought back their drop
for the ant lion mod mic 4.0 which has
been a community favorite for a long
time now speaking of which lonus has a
review of The Mod mic which was posted
two freaking years ago at this point but
if you do want to see his review of that
product you can check it out up here the
main idea behind the mod mic is a way to
turn your awesome audio file headphones
into a gaming ready headset without
sacrificing the awesome audio quality
that your headphones have it attaches
via a magnet system so it's easily
removed when you don't need it and the
magnets actually attached to the
headphone with 3M Adhesive pads so if
you ever want to remove it you won't
have any sticky residue on your beloved
headphones you can learn more about the
antl mod mic 4.0 and any other drops on
Mop at draw. SL
lt- ant lion and or you can just click
the link in the video description down
below
like the video if you liked it dislike
if you disliked it get subscribed either
way check with the Amazon link down
below to buy a graphics card if you want
to do that check out our shirt Link in
the video description down below as well
uh check go on the Forum if you want to
talk about new graphics cards try to
keep it civil I know everyone wants to
defend their purchasing decisions but
let's let's just try to keep this on a
Level Playing everyone everyone's just
trying to enjoy computer games we should
just keep it that way and just don't
worry about it I don't even know why I'm
still talking I'm just going to leave
check out the video on the screen if you
want to watch other
stuff